cycling you've got professional cycling
you've got World Tour side kind of
higher level now then you got the Tour
de France which kind of sits on its own
any person who raises the bicycle
whether on the road the track I think at
one point Chris Hoy would have wanted to
win something the Tour de France you
know any kid who rides a bicycle like
the Tour de France is the absolute
pinnacle like I said it figure the
syphon the general person in the street
you go to them and I'm cycling and say
what does the winner of the World
Championships we're in cycling most
people wouldn't know but you ask anybody
in the street it's a winner Tour de
France where every single person is
gonna say yellow joy and every single
person the Tour de France just has a
different meaning the consequences are
when you're losing or greater you know
you only have 21 opportunities a year to
win a sailor the Tour de France and
there and you have to take every single
one of them I could have worn every
other race on the planet but without the
Tour de France win
perhaps we the cyclist M 1 will be the
sports first man in Holland it and I all
that into a French really the victory
that stands out it was pretty special to
me that I don't think we're ever gonna
see it quite like that again in sight
and and that's my victory on the charms
of leaves I think it's my last time I
won on the shams new tune in 2012 and he
was getting led out by the yellow jersey
the Tour de France which is Brad Wiggins
he's almost my brother you know we
really weren't through everything
together through professional cycling in
2007-8 that was pretty special to be
part of a team as worn the Tour de
France
there's not many riders will get to
experience that in their career Sean's
alizée's
it's a special sprint it's the most
beautiful race finish is probably the
race finish that most people in the
world didn't know where does it sort of
French finish Chung's of either in Paris
you know it's a very hard trying to get
right there's a corner it's a bit too
far to go all the way from the corner to
the line it's slightly uphill it's on
cobblestones there's a certain line you
have to take on the cobbles to get the
the best out of it and and it's at the
end of three weeks of the to the fronts
and the hardest fight race in the world
so the hard one to get right and and you
have one known like different ways mm I
am special that yeah we nailed it so
right to the last corner my wrench or
second as well
as sports science and nutrition is
become important that's been in kind of
my generation and that's something we've
learned and that's definitely what what
I'm glad I live in this day and age for
we know our bodies we know different
people work in different ways different
people's physiology is different and the
more we understand that the more you can
tailor specific products to people and
their needs
the most important product in sports
nutrition that I've used throughout my
career is there is Regal is having the
right mix of protein the carbohydrate
immediately after I finish the stage you
see the rider crossed in the line well
you don't see what's gone from the cross
the line to see in the newspaper and
that's going on the podiums do $90
control it's interviewed with different
TVs different newspapers it's seeing the
fans and it can be a good few hours
before you get close to hotel ideally as
soon after you finish as you can you
need to replenish what your body's taken
out during that race and what you need
to recover for the day after and we go
extreme perfect you still stare as soon
as you cross the finish line
you
[Music]